president Trump's oldest son will return
to Capitol Hill to testify in a Senate
committees Russia investigation Donald
Trump jr. will appear next month he was
given a subpoena last week after
skipping requests to testify Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill Nancy good
morning good morning here's the
compromise they worked out Trump jr.
will show up but he'll only be
questioned for between two to four hours
behind closed doors by the Senate
Intelligence Committee this Agreement
struck after the White House and other
Republicans criticized the committee's
Republican chair Richard burr for
issuing a subpoena to compel Trump jr.
to testify burr has told colleagues that
he had no choice after Trump jr. backed
out of plans for a voluntary interview
the committee has questions about some
of the things that Trump jr. told
Congress the last time he was here about
his meeting with a Russian lawyer and
about a potential Trump Tower Moscow
deal back in 2016 his answers didn't
always match up with what the
president's former lawyer Michael
Michael Cohen and others told Congress
and that's why some Republicans like
Lindsey Graham are recommending that
Trump jr. show up in mid-june and simply
take the fifth and exercise his right to
avoid self-incrimination now CBS News
has also confirmed that the House
Intelligence Committee is probing
whether lawyers for the president and
his family may have obstructed that
committees Russia investigation by
trying to shape the testimony of some of
the witnesses including the president's
former lawyer Michael Cohen Norah so
Nancy will we see any or hear any of
Trump juniors testimony we will not
unless the committee decides to make a
transcript of it available after the
fact all right Nancy thank you